foreign
let's go out to Jenny in Toronto Canada
hey Jenny what's up
hi there John and Rachel thank you for
taking my call today you got it what's
up
um a couple days ago I found a deposit
slip in my car my husband had left there
that showed uh our small business
account had uh over six thousand dollars
in debt on it and uh I was on the
understanding that we were on baby steps
four five and six uh I confronted him
about it and he said oh that's all
overhead but have uh you know come up in
the last couple weeks and uh I went and
I looked at his last
um business bank statement as well and I
saw that it was actually uh over ten
thousand dollars in small business that
since before August
and this is a pretty big issue for us
because uh when we finished baby steps
three at the end of August I left my
corporate job to stay home with our two
kids so uh he is very sensitive about
this issue got very defensive when I
tried to talk to him so it's just uh
lying under the surface right now
um so how do I talk to him and do we use
our emergency fund to pay off this debt
uh two things here
um one this this has very little to do
with debt
this has to do with you finding out that
your husband stared you squaring the
eyes and lied to you
yeah and it's about something that you
two had both put your hands in and said
go team we're all in this together and
then he went and did this and so there's
it's not like y'all had never talked
about debt and you found a credit card
this is y'all are consciously working
towards building a different kind of
life and then this happened on the side
and then he lied to you about it
um anytime something like this pops up
like all of a sudden out of nowhere
somebody goes in and runs up 10 grand
and is trying to move this shell over
here and this shell over there
um
my my inclination right or wrong is
he seeing somebody or he's an addiction
has gotten out of control is there any
possibility of those two things
I would have said no but this is really
uh really shocked me really really
shocked me
um it's a he's always been sensitive
about finances because he took over a
family business
um this is family business
um and there was debt associated with
that and he had to have some tough
conversations with his mom which he
always is uh referencing but
I I need to ask him some tough straight
on questions about it and I mean
jokingly we had said you know is there
like you know who are you supporting and
he was just like no this is just
overhead costs this is what it takes to
run the business
well then your business is failing
underneath you
right yeah right and this isn't even
like a capital expense like he went and
bought a tractor for the farm this is
like paying light bills is what he's
trying to tell you is that right
yeah yeah and yeah
shipping fees yeah
um yeah Insurance fees but it didn't add
up so he yeah and that that's the part
that he didn't sit down and say Here's
the receipts here's where this is at I
shouldn't have done this I screwed up
um I got all these new invoices and I
panicked and I just opened up a quick
line of credit and paid this that's not
his response his response was you're
crazy you leave me alone
all I'm doing is this right yeah it's
always been a mess yes not my fault yeah
um and
there's a reason the word we use and we
don't we're not trying to oversell it
here
um here at Ram so we use the words
Financial infidelity
because it's that level of violation
when you find out the home the the
foundation of your home that you were
walking on is is suddenly not what you
thought it was
right and right my guess here is there's
something deeper here either he feels
like he is the son that was supposed to
keep his family business going and he is
unable to live in reality that this
business isn't solvent or
um
he's seeing somebody or like and that's
the problem with lying right is it opens
up the whole every door and window in
the house for scrutiny and questions
and so uh my experience has been when I
have these type of conversations and I
haven't had to have them with my wife
but I've had to have them with
co-workers before
um
I have to write it down otherwise I get
pretty pissed off and I get pretty
emotional I get pretty fired up and then
I stop thinking and then I get
accusatory and so I would write down
here's your concerns here's your
questions
and ask him directly I need direct
answers to these questions and here's
the overarching theme I no longer feel
safe in my home I don't feel safe in my
marriage with you because you have
violated my trust we're going to start
there and you get to feel you're not
going at him you lied you did this we're
talking about here's how I feel right
now and he can't deny that
right okay if you think he needs you
need a like a marriage counselor or
somebody in your community a couple that
you trust that can sit with you guys
that's cool
um but in my if I was doing if I was in
your exact shoes I would write these
things down Rachel what do you think no
it's a great yeah a great Point yeah and
Jenny I mean like in this if I were like
if that had happens in my household
right if I'm putting myself in your
shoes
the business issues the Tactical side of
the business whether it's failing like
that's that's down the road like I'm
gonna worry about that but I think
talking to him about like the like this
is a this is a marriage issue because in
his head he probably is I would think
still uh functioning at the level of
like oh gosh you found out about the
debt and he and it's still in a money
Sphere for him possibly with the with
possibly knowing oh gosh there might
this might get worse and deeper and I
think you coming at it as like as my
husband and our marriage like forget the
quote unquote money piece it's what John
said it's it's the lying like I you lied
to me you lied to me and here's the
facts of what I found and and we kind of
talk through this because I have to get
to a point again where where we rebuild
this trust because man this is this is
not this is not going to go well this is
not a good pattern
um and that's a and that's hard Jenny
like that's a hard conversation to have
do you guys in your marriage do you feel
um
like have y'all have y'all been able to
have like healthy conflict if you will
in marriage like do you feel like you
have a voice in the marriage all of that
or is this going to be like an out of
character thing for him to experience
you know like he's a good man and when
you know you said the thing about you
know he's the son who has to carry on
the family business and feeling that
responsibility something just went
playing in my heart because he said
things like that before like he has to
keep it going well let's let's put one
up let's put one more on there
you came to him at some point a year ago
six months ago and said I'm ready to
cash in all that I've worked for to get
my high paying corporate job because
I've been feeling
that the next chapter of my life was
going to be a stay-at-home mom and he
loves you so much he's like I'm all in
and wanted to do what he could to
support your dream just that maybe the
math isn't working out and so I can see
a scenario where he started trying to do
the best he could to keep your dream
alive the households dream alive or
maybe he pressured you into quitting
your job who knows but that on top of
hey you're this you're the we picked you
Golden Boy to keep the family business
going and people do wild things when
they start feeling pressure and it may
be that this is a conversation that
he will weep from he's been carrying
this so long there will be some peace in
his soul finally you know I mean because
shame it's brene Brown says shame eats
secrets for breakfast man he's probably
dying under the weight of this thing and
again this is the best case scenario
right yeah um that he was such a good
guy he tried to find every Avenue and
ended up finding himself over his head
and then he started lying about it cool
we can work from that or worst case
scenario he's got somebody else right
and he is blowing through money left and
right who knows
um there's just not another way
um to heal from this except right
through the middle of it and
I would go in very clear what I was
going to say and go in very much here's
how I'm experiencing this now you did
and you did here's what I'm experiencing
and here's what I'm about to do about it
unless we get real clear real fast
and we'll be thinking about you if you
get a moment call us back and let us
know how things went after this
conversation I'd like to follow up with
our audience on it thank you so much for
trusting us this is the Ramsey Show
we'll be right back